visitando algunos de los heridos de este
hospital podemos hacernos una idea de lo
que significa luchar en una ciudad que
los rusos consideran estratégica estos
soldados ucranianos se salvaron de
milagro cuando un misil de crucero ruso
cayó sobre su base a las afueras de la
ciudad pero muchos de sus hermanos de
armas no tuvieron tanta suerte
cuando el misil nos alcanzó el edificio
empezó a derrumbarse desde el tercer
piso yo estaba en el segundo y me
encontré en el primero atrapado bajo el
hormigón yo con la pierna rota pero no
pasa nada no pasa nada lo superaré se
doble a los barcos rusos que se jodan
desde el inicio de la ofensiva han
ingresado 160 soldados pero la mayoría
de las bajas han sido civiles como esta
mujer que vive en un pueblo donde los
rusos han conseguido afianzarse
había muchos tanques y helicópteros y
los soldados rusos quieren comer así que
se meten en las casas para encontrar
comida espero que los aviones bombardean
a estos soldados por lo que han hecho
como loteo echad boulet
las fuerzas rusas han atacado zonas
civiles con la esperanza de capturar la
estratégica ciudad que con esta que
conoces a un cohete impactó en este
edificio situado cerca de una base aérea
pero los jóvenes que se encuentran en su
interior no tienen intención de evacuar
a todo el mundo estaba conmocionado
había niños nos despertó una primera
explosión que golpeó el edificio y luego
otras todo tembló y el yeso se cayó del
techo todos tenían pánico me quedaré
aunque dure no hay nada que podamos
hacer
la vida ha dado un vuelco desde que
comenzó la invasión rusa y los
habitantes de mykolaiv son conscientes
de que lo peor está por llegar